president zielinski arrived in the
ancient Westminster Hall to a rapturous
welcome
both houses of Parliament on their feet
for the wartime leader some here compare
to former British prime minister Winston
Churchill
[Applause]
of our lifetime it will be a victory
over the very idea of the war
after we went together any aggressor it
doesn't matter big or small will know
what awaits him if he attacks
International order
Beyond his gratitude for Britain's
support zelinski was here to deliver a
singular request his appeal for combat
aircraft inscribed on a Ukrainian
fighter Pilot's helmet
we have freedom it said give us Wings to
protect it and I appeal to you and the
world was simple and yet most important
words
combat aircrafts for Ukraine wings for
Freedom there's no denying the Ukrainian
president's popularity nor the rousing
support for his cause but allies who
only recently agreed to give thanks to
Ukraine worry now that providing fighter
jets may be an escalation too far
entering Downing Street earlier to the
unusual Applause of the staff
yeah
president zielinski carried a message
that was all too clear if you want us to
win this war give us what we need to do
it
foreign
message no doubt reiterated that
Buckingham Palace where he met King
Charles III
great honor to be here thank you
one time for me and a message repeated
to Ukrainian troops being trained by
British forces on the plains of
Southwest England
in response prime minister Rishi sunak
said the supply of combat aircraft was
part of an ongoing conversation and that
a first step would be expanding
Britain's training program to include
teaching Ukrainian Pilots how to fly
NATO standard Jets
that is a significant step that
President zielinski will use to press
other allies Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
London